[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition 1ère édition du
club de la presse sur tv 78 la chaîne
des yvelines une émission retransmise
sur l fm radio 95 x 5
plusieurs journalistes autour de cette
table hakima est un bon jour avec
tristan chef de l fm lahbib eddaouidi
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le directeur
des gazettes gazette de saint quentin et
gazette en yvelines également et puis
dans le dans le 92 aussi sur la défense
la gazette de develier z de la ville
fried et puis alexandre remarquer
bonjour un responsable du secteur de
saint-quentin pour toutes les nouvelles
journal également retrouver sur le 7-8
actus.fr bienvenue à vous trois à
bienvenue à tous et à toutes
au sommaire de ce club de la presse
focus sur les violences urbaines dans
les yvelines des violences qui ont
trouvé leur point d'orgue avec les
émeutes survenues au début du mois à
chanteloup-les-vignes comment les médias
ont-ils traiter cette information
nous reviendrons sur les conclusions du
grenelle sur les violences conjugales
avec les conclusions dans le département
politique également avec la fusion qui
se précise entre les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine et la campagne des
municipales aussi et qui s'accélère dans
certaines communes et puis où en est on
avec le traitement des conséquences de
l'incendié de la station d'épuration à
saint germain en laye c'était en juillet
dernier avant de refermer ce club de la
presse nous verrons aussi quelles sont
les personnalités du mois à l'honneur
fabienne lauret féministe et christophe
ouest danseurs et puis deux grands chefs
versaillais qui s'installe à temps le
gault et millau
nous sommes le 22 novembre coup d'envoi
de ce premier club de la presse avec
l'actualité du mois
[Musique]
et l'actualité principale de ces
dernières semaines ce sont les violences
urbaines elles ont fait la une des
médias avec une nuit d'émeutes qui a vu
partir en fumée
début novembre un bâtiment culturel
emblématique de la ville de chanteloup
une oreille est inaugurée par dont il ya
tout juste un an à ce bâtiment à
arch un chapiteau où les jeunes
s'initier aux arts du cirque avant d'en
parler autour de cette table avec les
journalistes du département voici le
reportage réalisé par tv et 78 nous en
parlons juste après même s'il tient
encore debout le chapiteau de la
compagnie des contraire n'est pas au
mieux de sa forme
dans la nuit du 2 au 3 novembre ce lieu
culturel situé dans le quartier de la
noé à chanteloup les vignes a été la
cible d'un incendie criminel sous les
yeux des habitants
j'étais apeuré françois m'a vraiment
attristé de voir un centre culturel
comme ça brûle et à cause des changes
entre policiers et jeunes de quartiers
inauguré l'an dernier large propose aux
jeunes de s'initier aux arts du cirque
et de la danse
un espace culturel qui accueille
également des spectacles
la perte matérielle se chiffre à plus
d'un million d'euros qui a tout le
matériel qui est nécessaire au cirque
que c'est un matériel qui coûterait très
cher des installations extrêmement
importantes ça va falloir le chiffre il
ya tout le matériel qui servait aussi à
au spectacle parce que c'était aussi un
lieu de spectacle c'était un lieu d'art
sous toutes les formes
ce chapiteau est géré par l'association
la compagnie des contraires présente
depuis près de 30 ans dans la ville le
département des yvelines a décidé de
prendre en charge l'intégralité de la
reconstruction de la structure
lorsque ces cités populaires sont
confrontés à cet océan de connerie j'ai
fini par dire mon mot eh bien nous
serons là aux côtés des maires mais quel
qu'il soit on va reconduire le même le
même
voilà donc c'est pas compliqué on a les
plans il suffit de reprendre on refait
un appel d'offres jeu
il faudra d'ailleurs qu'on voit si il
est même possible de faire un appel
d'offres restreint enfin il faut aller
vite dans moins de noirs et inaugurer ce
bâtiment sa relance le sourire sa
relance l'espoir et je pense que dès
lors au moment où la population va
entendre ça aussi les élèves et tous les
enfants qui viennent si l'espoir va
revenir
en plus de la reconstruction du
chapiteau le département des yvelines va
allouer une aide exceptionnelle à la
ville de chanteloup les vignes pour
notamment renforcer ses équipes de
sécurité et de médiation les violences
urbaines c'est donc le sujet d'actualité
de ce mois pour le club de la presse à
kimaya rédactrice en chef de l ai fait
ma radio c'était c'était surprenant ce
qui s'est passé sur chanteloup est ce
que finalement il y avait aussi une
grande une colère un petit peu comment
vous l'avez ressenti sur le terrain
oui c'était sûr enfin évidemment on
pouvait pas s'attendre à un événement
aussi aussi impressionnant maintenant
sur place ce qu'on a ressenti évidemment
c'est ce qu'on a pu voir sur le sujet
savoir catherine arenou très affecté
très mobilisé et puis rapidement qui a
souhaité reprend garder le cap
une colère des élus oui on l'a entendu
de pierre bédier le département et nous
alors on a une particularité elles fm
radio c'est qu'on a quand même une
antenne
annexe donc on connaît bien la ville et
d'ailleurs on travaille avec la jeunesse
de chanteloup lors des ateliers radio et
on connaît on connaissait bien la
structure
donc on couvrait des sujets régulier et
ils se sont sentis assez abattu donc
peut-être
ah oui forcément ah oui oui complètement
oui quels ont été les retours des jeunes
aussi à ça on entendu beaucoup les
politiques aussi alors après dans vos
médias respectifs vous nous direz si
vous avez donner aussi la parole aux
jeunes comment ils ont réagi par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé et qui utilisait
cette structure intime c'était une
condamnation et puis une grande
tristesse et beaucoup d'affect même
constat lahbib eddaouidi directeur des
gazettes
oui mais juste pour répondre à votre
question juste avant surprenant oui et
non serbes tout dépend de la position
dans laquelle on se positionne en tant
qu acteur extérieur entre guillemets en
toc citoyen on la perçoit pas forcément
mais je crois savoir en tout cas que
beaucoup d' indice donné la tendance qui
avait quelques difficutés que ça allait
vraisemblablement explosé d'ailleurs on
a su bien après que que les les agents
de police locaux avaient fait des notes
concernant cette montée de violence
donc peut-être que l'état un môme on n'a
pas su réagir en tout cas au moment où
tout cas l'information n'est pas arrivé
aux bons canaux mais mais ensuite ce qui
est très surprenant c'est qu'on l'a vu
dans toutes les manifestations de
solidarité etc
c'est beaucoup de politiques c'est
beaucoup de 2010 c'est beaucoup
d'acteurs qui sont tous de venir sur le
terrain
et oui on comprend qu'il soit quelques
bars extérieurs à l'événement moi j'ai
été très surpris par le fait que hormis
le microcosme politique n'y a pas eu de
manifestations très forte on l'a vu
d'ailleurs manifestation de dimanche
dernier les habitants les acteurs locaux
sont très peu présents c'est assez
surprenant pourquoi ils ne prennent pas
la parole alors c'est qui est une
certain fatalisme aussi peut-être est
peut-être un certain fallait taddei mais
aussi aussi
un fait c'est qu'on est dans un dans un
contexte où clairement c'est les
minorités qui ont pris pouvoir dans les
quartiers comme ailleurs d'ailleurs on
le voit bien que une mine poignée de
deux crétins parce qu'il faut être
crétin moment faire ce qu'ils ont fait
une poignée de crétins impose une
certaine loi à une une écrasante
majorité ils compris des papas des
mamans des habitants de ces quartiers
quand je dîne police est vraiment une
poignée mais avant on disait que c'était
justement les anciens les grands frères
aussi qu'ils tenaient peut-être un petit
peu cessé quelques crétins on va les
appeler comme ça aujourd'hui c'est plus
qu'à parce qu'aujourd'hui la fin d'un
enfin la jeunesse qui arrive en tout cas
ces gosses qui ont 15 18 19 cents
rencontres là et je pense que c'est pas
par hasard que le système scolaire s'en
sortent tous les ans 180 mille jeunes
sans diplôme et c'est jallet se
retrouvent le plus souvent dans nos
quartiers et donc il ya une réponse qui
doit être un peu plus qu'une réponse
sécuritaire et je pense que y compris en
passant par par une implication plus
forte des parents et puis faut casser
cette peur parce que il ya une vraie
l'installation une via l'installation
d'une peur dans nos quartiers et pas
seulement imposée par une petite
minorité
alexander marqué oui à qui ma maison
après alexandre remarquer que oui je
rejoindrai la bible effectivement là
dessus sur les symptômes de la montée
c'est vrai que quand je disais qu'on a
été surpris c'est de l'ampleur de des
dégâts mais c'est vrai qu'on a suivi
tous les toutes les dégradations
notamment sur l'éclairage et puis la
difficulté qu'a la ville à maintenir
entre guillemets la sécurité puisque en
fait les éclairages sont
systématiquement détruit le jour même ça
veut dire qu'il ya des équipes
municipales qui interviennent maintenant
il faut se poser la question de pourquoi
ces jeunes souhaitent dans le noir oui
on rit c'est la question du stress que
ça gêne un peu leur trafic voilà pour
mettre les pieds de sécurité alexandre
marqué pour toutes les nouvelles vous
êtes vous êtes rendu sera champion s'est
rendu sur place le soir même j'ai été
prévenue par un mes collègues
du courrier menthe je suis arrivé là-bas
vers vers 23 heures
donc là ce moment là ils ont été les
premiers médias ont armé les premiers
et pas beaucoup d'habitants dans les
rues on a croisé qui le
l'ancien maire un pierre cardo et puis
bien sûr policiers et pompiers qui
étaient larache pied sur sur l'incident
et le quartier a été assez calme était
redevenue assez calme paradoxalement
après ce qui s'était passé j'ai parlé
quelques habitants qui étaient étonnés
de nous voir là justement tunisie vous
n'avez pas peur d'être là où une chose
comme ça c'était assez paradoxal et puis
bien sûr le lendemain matin quand
quand tous les jours est revenu voilà
tous les médias sont arrivés avec et
tous les politiques là c'était un
déferlement médiatique avec on va en
parler à tous les médias nationaux
tous les médias nationaux sont venus on
peut parler du traitement peut-être des
médias nationaux vous qui intervenait
sur sur le terrain du département des
yvelines
le traitement dans les médias nationaux
est-ce que c'était cohérent avec ce qui
se passe c est ce que c'était
stigmatisant est-ce que c'était à la
hauteur la ville y a pas de
stigmatisation contient un fait divers
aussi aussi violent pour une petite
commune parce qu'en réalité
surtout l'insee 5000 ou 6000 habitants
on n'est pas dans une ondée part au val
fourré ou n'est pas de trappe on n'est
pas dans des grandes cités ouvrières ou
pas d'ailleurs
donc c'est ce qui est choquant les plus
vains et quand on voit chanteloup petite
ville et qui certainement à une autorité
mauvaise l'autorité qui est devenue
nationale et c'est assez impressionnant
notoriété si on remonte à 1995 il ya le
film la haine qui est sortie était à
béton s'est tourné à chanteloup aussi
pour revenir un petit vol a justement ce
que j'allais dire c'est que ce qui est
malheureux c'est que je chante ou jouit
d'une mauvaise réputation depuis les
années 70 a longtemps été appelé chicago
en yvelines 1995 kassovitz bien tourné
la haine et la réputation et encore
c'est encore pire
ils ont traîné ça comme un boulet
pendant des années après lui la vague de
rénovation urbaine qui a fait du bien à
la ville qui a changé un peu le visage
de la ville et puis patatras des
événements comme ça qui font que
c'est à dire faire on ne peut rien faire
ça c'est commune il ya un filtre est
alité et sur certaines autres communes
là on parle de ce qui s'est passé à
chanteloup mais ça touche d'autres
communes du département il ya eu entre
la jolie eva joly eu des nuits de
tension aussi à plaisir sur quartier du
vally bowie était pareil sur le quartier
du val hibou il ya toute une politique
de rénovation l'anru une deuxième phase
encore qui est lancé et ça ne changera
rien trappe c'est pareil 360 millions
injectés en disant là un nouveau
programme qui est partie et malgré tout
régulièrement il ya des violences
urbaines ya eu 2013 suite à un contrôle
d'identité qu'elle ait mal tourné de
2015 il ya la mort du jeune moussa un
règlement de comptes entre entre ses
mains régulièrement ça revient malgré
tout cette montée de violence n'est pas
propre aux yvelines 20 les violences des
ailes et nationales et puis elle est
aussi quelque part et indirectement les
faits des gis les geôles de toutes ces
tensions qu'on voit en permanence dans
dans notre télévision et dans notre
chaîne d'information continue on en voit
un peu moins chez vous heureusement
d'ailleurs
mais mais quelque part ça serait presque
logique qui est qui et les explosions
aussi dans les quartiers
puisqu'aujourd'hui on rentre dans des
défis sur les réseaux sociaux etc tard
ce qui fait qu'il est une incitation
insidieuse à la violence qu'on le
veuille ou non il ya un jeu avec les
réseaux sociaux ont tout de même aussi
c'est ça c'est on va piéger les
policiers on va piéger les pompiers ont
le film et puis c'est celui qui fera le
plus de vues et des petits commentaires
sympas
vous parliez de plaisir de ses villas
dans lesquels on
on a effectivement mis en place des
plans de rénovation urbaine alors c'est
utile pour répondre à la question qui
était posée c'est pas inutile d
simplement ça change les choses en
surface évidemment c'est à dire que
quand on se balade dans ces quartiers là
on a tout d'un coup de très jolies
fresques murales ça change le décor mais
en réalité
sociologiquement parlant rien ne change
on est toujours avec des familles et qui
vivent dans une très grande précarité
majoritairement canton par canton de
laon vie dans ces bâtiments lacan six
cantons quand on rentre dans ses
bâtiments là on se rend bien compte qu'à
l'intérieur les rénovations elles sont
pas elles ne vont pas jusque jusqu'à
leur terme donc sont déjà il ya un
climat et moi je distinguerai je ne
mettrai pas forcément de lien avec les
gilet jaune parce que pour moi il ya une
constance dans l'histoire des de ces
quartiers là c'est que en dépit de plan
de rénovation
il n'y a pas eu de grandes avancées
notamment d'ailleurs les politiques
d'intégration sur l'emploi donc les
économies alternatives restent telles
qu'elles ont été telle qu'on a pu les
voir dans le film la haine ou enfin ces
trafics sont pas des mythes
effectivement sont pas des mines qui
sont des réalités
maintenant la politique c'est aussi
répondre à ces questions là donc
aujourd'hui qui attendent les
populations du travail déjà tout
simplement je crois c'est 20% de chômage
est donc du coup il ya pas mal de jeunes
qui traînent dans la rue et est plutôt
que de s'embêter bas et préfère embêter
les autres on va laisser de côté pour ce
numéro du club de la presse ce sujet des
violences urbaines et nous allons
intéressé à présent aux autres sujets
qui ont fait l'actualité ce mois-ci
[Musique]
votre sujet à la une le grenelle contre
les violences conjugales il prend
officiellement fin le lundi 25 novembre
la concertation a engrangé engagé
forcément de fortes attentes quand
concertation qui est passé par les
yvelines premiers éléments de réponse
sur ce qui est ressorti de cette
opération sur le plan local avec
marielle savina elle est déléguée
départementale aux droits des femmes et
à l'égalité dans les yvelines elle était
récemment sur le plateau de tv 78 les
quotas avant tout c'est un état des
lieux et la volonté et la nécessité de
coordonner l'ensemble des acteurs qu'ils
soient des acteurs locaux où ça soit
décès
de l'état ne serait que le besoin de
coordination donc l'idée c'est de créer
un réseau des réseaux c'est à dire que
il ya plusieurs réseaux un peu partout
dans les yvelines ce soit au nord au sud
au centre de notre département
donc l'idée c'est de créer deux réseaux
alors un sud où va pouvoir se rencontrer
l'ensemble des acteurs se concerter
faire des guides de bonnes pratiques et
faire remonter au niveau du réseau qui
serait le réseau a piloté par la
préfecture et le parquet en tout cas des
bonnes initiatives qu'on pourrait
renforcer et développer ce que l'idée
c'est ça existe fondamentalement ça
existe nous avons tous il faut juste
mettre en musique et faire de la
synergie marielle savina déléguée
départementale aux droits des femmes et
à l'égalité dans le département des
yvelines lahbib eddaouidi pour les
gazettes vous aviez consacré un des
numéros de la gazette de saint quentin
en yvelines sur ces violences justement
conjuguer évidemment et puis vint dans
une société on peut pas se satisfaire de
faire en permanence le constat sauf que
ça fait des décennies qu'on fait que le
constat de ces violences conjugales et
notamment de ces violences envers les
femmes
la réponse elle doit être pénale doit
être ferme parce que on peut pas
continuer à vivre dans une société d'un
autre société de cette manière avec un
comportement à l'égard de la gente
féminine et de ces violences et que la
réponse doit être très forte et très et
pénales et à partir de là il ya que
comme ça qu'on réussira à réduire lé les
faire disparaître dans la société
un constat les signalements sont en
hausse sur le département depuis
l'ouverture de ce grenelle déjà le
constater sur le terrain il ya eu des
interventions des uns et des autres vous
êtes rendus dans vos médias respectifs
sur ces auprès des associations qui
oeuvrent a besoin après les faits oui
absolument alors à l excès non plus
c'est vrai que notre ligne éditoriale
forcément nous nous enjoint nous
encourage à s'intéresser plus
particulièrement à cette thématique là
en tant que média qui a la prétention de
s'appeler la plus féminine des radios
s'intéresse à ces sujets là
au delà du grenelle au quotidien et
c'est vrai qu'il ya une hausse des
signalements c'est ce qu'on a pu
constater on reçoit déjà dans le mur
très régulièrement les acteurs et puis
les
de ces associations telles que lucie
robin la directrice du cidff qui
effectivement nous confirment qu'il ya
une augmentation alors une augmentation
que par exemple à l analyse comme étant
la conséquence de cette communication
c'est à dire que le fait de parler
davantage ça veut pas dire
nécessairement que la société puis plus
violente mais peut-être que la parole a
été libéré et que mon père soit là faut
libérer que la parole se libère grâce à
des affaires comme dsk ou robben
schweinsteiger ont permis de libérer
cette parole je pense et sur le
département des yvelines aussi a
malheureusement ça n'empêche pas le laos
des féminicides il y en a eu quatre
jusqu'à présent sa plainte ce qui ce qui
est quand même assez assez assez pharand
est ce qu'il ya des pistes et des choses
qui ressortent des associations qui se
mobilisent que vous avez pu mettre à
l'honneur les uns les autres
ah oui il ya des pistes alors on en
parlera tout à l'heure on me suis fait
des féministes du mantois avec notamment
la présence de fabienne lauret
une des explications c'est plus plus ses
campagnes de communication sont mises en
avant plus une espèce d'effet mécanique
et une résistance
deux des agresseurs qui veulent asseoir
un petit peu leur emprise et maintenir
leur rôle donc ça peut être une piste
alors il ya autre chose de très
intéressant que j'ai entendues lors
d'une interview ce jeu est un jeune
auteur du manque la jolie du val fourré
qui s'appelle benjamin mon cas là et qui
a écrit un recueil de poèmes autour des
violences conjugales et qui a amené
l'idée selon laquelle en fait on
s'occupait peut-être effectivement
beaucoup des victimes mais pas
suffisamment de l'accompagnement des
agresseurs or on ne peut pas enfin si on
veut avoir une prise en compte globale
ça devrait être fait selon lui et j'ai
trouvé ça effectivement assez pertinents
accompagnement des agresseurs
l'accompagnement est effectivement des
agresseurs qui sont aussi alors c'est
politiquement incorrect de dire ça mais
on s'entend mais selon le point de vue
de cet auteur intelligent ses agresseurs
sont aussi dans un état de souffrance
mais c'est un cercle de violence dont
qui la lie à la la souffrance que l'on
commet et puis la souffrance subie mais
olivier con que les que les chiffres les
chiffres sont au laos
mais la réalité c'est qu'on est encore
en dessous de la réalité puisque mais
tout n'est pas signalée évidemment
énormément de femmes hésitent encore à
le signaler et dans toutes les franges
de la société enfin c'est pas ce n'est
pas une caractéristique bien
particulière à tel ou tel parti ou deux
composantes de notre société c'est que
les violences faites aux femmes sont
dans tous les échelons de notre société
et malheureusement elles ne sont pas
suffisamment dénoncé par les pouvoirs
publics aujourd'hui quoique sur les sur
les quatre dernières années
il ya vraiment une volonté manifeste de
régler notamment
je suis pas fan de de la mise des droits
des femmes et je trouve qu'elle fait un
qu'elle fait face à 10
faut-il mais mais mais mais qu'elle fait
qu'elle fait un boulot remarquable en
tout cas en matière de communication
fait un boulot remarquable qu'il faut
souligner et je pense que avec sept
ministres à la tête de ce ministère
j'ai le sentiment en tout cas qu'on en
parle beaucoup plus c'est que ça évolue
dans le bon sens a passé des risques
aussi faut pas qu'il faut pas que ça
devienne juste une énième opération de
communication et des vrais moyens soient
mis sur ce qu'il faudra voir les
résultats de ce grenelle justement à
partir du 25 il ya plusieurs pistes un
améliorer l'accueil des victimes ont
commencé hier l'association table ronde
bon et justement vous parlez de
communication effectivement un des
éléments qui expliquent que les femmes
victimes de violence on ne porte pas
plainte c'est qu'elles savent que
derrière les solutions et notamment les
solutions et les solutions d'hébergement
ne suivent pas donc en réalité libérer
la parole encore une fois c'est bien
mais ensuite il faut préparer l'après
ski pour l'instant au vu des moyens
déployés par le gouvernement même si ça
a été annoncé comme cause nationale
l'égalité femmes hommes pour l'instant
c'est pas encore totalement à l'ordre du
jour par les dépister à garantir
l'indépendance économique des victimes
aussi on est en plein dedans on verra ce
qui est annoncé et une bonne
communication peut amener une
frustration énorme si les oreilles du
loup dans l'unique but on est exposé
dans les médias si derrière il n'y a pas
de résultats de choses concrètes en tout
cas qui sortent et est ce que les
associations relève dans leur ensemble
c'est que pour le moment en dehors de la
communication s'assume pas un numéro 1
tout de même pour signaler aider aussi
ses victimes de violence le 39 19
on va parler d'un tout autre sujet dans
ce club de la presse sur tv 78 transmis
aussi sur lfm parlant d' instits sas la
station la situation à la station
d'épuration des eaux du siaap
elle est à saint germain en laye hr1 feu
a éclaté début juillet sur ce site un
incendie de grande ampleur qui a détruit
partiellement ce qui est à ce jour la
plus grande station d'épuration d'europe
puisqu'ils ont entraîné une vaste
pollution de la senne les réunions de
suivi se sont multipliés depuis trois
quatre mois la situation et ce jour avec
le préfet des yvelines une amélioration
substantielle va avoir lieu à partir du
14 novembre
puis des travaux complémentaires vont
être engagés notamment pour la détection
incendie et ces travaux seront terminés
au 28 février prochain et puis nous
aurons un retour progressif à la pleine
capacité
mais en effet ça prend du temps environ
quatre années encore
le préfet des yvelines quand on parle de
pollution importante c'est plus de 10
tonnes de poissons morts 1 surtout et la
pollution aussi qui peut revenir parce
que depuis trois mois et demi
justement le traitement des eaux se fait
a minima donc en cas de forte pluie
d'inondations on pourrait avoir des
épisodes encore de pollution assez fort
est ce que dans vos différents médias
les uns et les autres que ce soit pour
la gazette que ce soit pour aller faire
mon corps les nouvelles vous avez
l'impression d'avoir assez
d'informations ou est-ce que ça a été
assez opaque la communication autour de
ce qui est survenu
hakima non quatre mois plus tard il ya
toujours un certain flou il ya une
atmosphère d'omerta en fait ça ressemble
ce qui s'est passé à rouen effectivement
il ya quand même des éléments
d'information comme on vient de le voir
mais sont des données qui nous échappe
alors nous on a déjà on est un petit peu
hors secteur saint germain si vous
voulez on a traité ça on à intégrer ça
dans nos flash très peu de sujets très
peu d' enquête là-dessus et puis de par
contre on s'est mis à la place des deux
des auditeurs donc on est allé à la
rencontre des auditeurs dans nos micros
trottoirs au quotidien et ça fait
vraiment partie d inquiétude montante du
point de vue de la société alors j'étais
plus inquiet sur le nuage noir de rouen
parce que forcément enfin vous mais
voilà on est du côté de mantes-la-jolie
donc il ya cette inquiétude qui était
qui était réel et puis un sentiment
d'être complètement mis à gauche à la
fin vraiment ce qui fait qu'on se pose
beaucoup de questions sur fait si tu dis
seveso ces sites qui ont normalement une
sécurité particulier alexandre marqué
pour les nouvelles toutes les nouvelles
vous aviez justement c'est un une
enquête un reportage sur ces sites
seveso celui de coignières peut-être 14
dans les îles et de droits dont
notamment où il ya à coignières c'est
une raffinerie en dépôt pétrolier
justement le maire et quelques temps
avait interpellé le préfet sur le sujet
parce qu'il ya quelques incidents graves
accidents s'étaient déroulées ces
derniers mois ces dernières années il
voulait interpeller le préfet sur le
sujet savoir un peu ce qui s'est passé
dans ce dépôt pétrolier et c'est vrai
pour revenir sur ce que disait inquiet
mais je trouve qu'on n'a pas et n'en
parle et finalement de l' incendie de
cacher dans les médias nationaux ont
parlé tout à l'heure de chef de chant le
clou par exemple qui a été énorme
rappelle alors qu'un incendie d'achères
a été beaucoup plus faible s'est passé
quasiment inaperçu pour parer à
l'incendié de rouen lubrizol
alors que les conséquences sont
importantes et finalement c'est que
c'est seulement quand il ya eu des
dizaines de tonnes de poissons morts que
là les médias nationaux ont commencé un
peu à s'y intéresser
parce que ça du visible c'est comme à
rouen ce nuage de fumée ça devient
visible ça intéresse les médias
forcément qui est
moi je partage pas en fait la position
de d'hakima sur le fait que qu'on n'ait
pas eu suffisamment d'information
d'avant on est sur un fait divers
exceptionnelle sur l'un des plus grands
sites d'europe et je trouve que les
services de l'état ont été très réactifs
je trouve que ils ont donné un maximum
d'informations en tout cas à la presse
ils ont énormément communiqué la
préfecture a organisé à la sous
préfecture de saint germain énormément
de réunions ouvert à la presse et à
peut-être que le jeu politique derrière
n'a peut-être pas été à la hauteur parce
que les politiques ont à la proche d'une
élection donc c'est rentrer dans une
sorte de deux ils sont rentrés dans une
polémique qui ne sert pas l'intérêt
général et dans ce cas là oui je trouve
que la polémique orchestrée par les
politiques dans cet événement ne servait
pas l'international
mais je trouve qu'en matière de
communication lui quand même énormément
d'infos songez pas le sentiment que les
services de l'état et notamment la
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye
et essayer de dissimuler quoi que ce
soit c'est sur les conséquences
écologiques mesurer l'impact écologique
de ses ancêtres
finalement et d'ailleurs il n'y a pas eu
de plan d'intervention particulier parce
que normalement on est sur un site
seveso et lorsqu'il se passe ce genre
d'événement il ya tout un plan qui se
met en place derrière pour protéger les
populations comme ça a pu être le cas
avant la ja pas il n'ya pas du sérail le
jour j on est quand même sur un fait
divers rabou du dans des circonstances
assez assez exceptionnel donc il faut
aussi de l'intégration
on peut reprocher beaucoup de choses aux
uns et aux autres et notamment à ceux
qui décident parce que nous on est
quelque part même dans nos jours l'un
des commentateurs enfin les personnes
qui sont qui doivent trancher que ça
tarde quand ils ont des situations comme
celle-ci effectivement ils peuvent
commettre des erreurs de communication
puisque je je n'ai pas eu le sentiment
sur ce fait divers par les politiques
justement on va s'intéresser un peu à la
politique à présent la fusion des
yvelines des hauts-de-seine qui se
concrétise un peu plus chaque jour au
delà de la mise en commun de moyens dans
différents secteurs une avancée
significative le 5 novembre avec
l'audition des deux présidents
département yvelines et autres scènes
c'est à l'assemblée nationale pour
expliquer un peu leur lors des marches
extraits de ces auditions justement nous
avons fusionné nos services à plus de
50% nous y avons d'ailleurs fait des
gains de productivité très important et
notre objectif c'est d'atteindre 200
millions d'économies chaque année dans
par le seul fait de cette fusion ça nous
a rendu aussi beaucoup plus efficace
pour nous département des yvelines on
voit bien qu'il ya un risque de
glissement de richesse et nous voulons
accompagner ce mouvement puisque nous
voyons bien que ça parle naturellement
avec l'ogcn et que ce serait trop long
de vous l'expliquer mais nos populations
sont les mêmes nos entreprises sont les
mêmes nuno fluides sont les mêmes on est
les mêmes en réalité pierre bédier puis
juste auparavant patrick devedjian
président lui des des hauts-de-seine
qu'on aperçoit sur cette photo si on
peut la voir aussi en plein écran la
photo qui est juste derrière nous ils
s'entendent bien tous les deux cette
fusion semble semble aller dans le bon
sens on dirait une photo de mariage
presque
lahbib eddaouidi alors sur de l'argile
alors sur le fait qu'ils s'entendent
bien oui j'ai confiance
ce sont deux présidents qui travaillent
main dans la main mais je pense que il
n'y a pas de doute là dessus
ça fait des années qu'ils travaillent
sur cette fille girons à la ruse ça
s'accélère un peu mais ça fait quand
même depuis est depuis 2007 il ya eu
beaucoup de choses qui ont été mises en
commun je vais leur préciser il ya la
voirie qu'il ya l'archéologie préventive
aussi l'adoption et le déploiement du
numérique à la fusion divine numérique
avec les hauts-de-seine et ça c'est ça
lieu d'ailleurs aujourd'hui 22 novembre
et puis un fonds d'investissement de 150
millions d'euros avec cinq autres
départements franciliens voilà pour les
mises en commun concrètes dont le lieu
et son émission complémentaire ces deux
départements fin on a le département le
plus riche de france qui sont les
siennes sur un petit périmètre
vingt départements limitrophes les
yvelines qui vaste qui peut et qui peut
récupérer une certaine d'entreprise
l'idée c'est vraiment de mutualiser
aussi des services mutualisés
l'ensemble des projets je trouve ça
idiot alors après je suis pas sûr que le
gouvernement le voit d'un bon oeil en
tout cas il se presse pas de là une idée
si pâle
oui c'est sap avant les municipales une
6e quelques fuites finalement ça a été
re clarifier ce sera pas avant les
municipales
si c'est mal vu aussi c'est parce que
dans un premier temps c'était aussi un
peu une perçue comme une offensive pour
lutter contre ce grand paris pour pas en
être exclu sur le sur le terrain les que
que pour mon possible peut-être les
habitants et ce cas une inquiétude
particulière devant les frites
j'essaie différentes communes
aujourd'hui dans lesquels on exclut un
petit peu en tout cas le département des
yvelines
voilà le grand paris ce n'est pas vous
ne sentez pas en tant que citoyen membre
de ce grand paris citoyens du grand
paris voilà maintenant mais je pense
même que même le grand paris ne souhaite
pas forcément conçoivent sourire de
scorpa il faut remettre les choses à
leur place mais
le grand paris on les yvelines en tout
cas ne sont pas concernés puis rappelons
que le grand paris l'idée c'était qui
avait été un moment fortement réfléchie
par par l'elysée c'était d'intégrer les
hauts-de-seine
en fait tous les départements le 94 et
93 et de faire un grand paris qui
consisterait à plutôt à un grand paris
les riches et que ça c'est tombé à
l'autre
concernant le la disparition des trois
départements et qu'aujourd'hui il ya
plein d'options il ya plein d'optique
sur la table mais je suis pas sûr que le
gouvernement ait envie de transfert très
vite sur cette question parce que au
fond ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on crée une grosse structure qui
économiquement pèsera énormément et qui
peut être un contre-pouvoir à la région
peut être un contre-pouvoir très fort au
grand paris tant voulue par président de
la république auquel sa pause ça pose
une multitude de questions à laquelle
c'est bien qu'ils les lisent et n'a pas
encore été une décision soit prise avant
les élections départementales de 2021
parce que kita quitte à voter et causé
des pertes allant talent autant autant
savoir effectivement elle puis le nombre
d'élus aussi parce qu'il va falloir
fusionner ces deux absences et deux
assemblées c'est toujours compliqué en
fusionnant les assembler un moment ça
avait été évoquée avec même la
disparition des départements alors
aujourd'hui on parle de fusion alors
qu'à un moment on parlait de de faire
disparaître certains certains
départements
les habitants les uns les autres se
retrouvent encore moi je vais faire un
jeu sur le sol son père on n'a pas le
sentiment que cette question de la
fusion préoccupe beaucoup les habitants
alain déjà le départ témoins ont du mal
à savoir un peu ce que c'est quelles
sont ses compétences hormis en mille
collage et la voirie donc une fusion
entre les deux départements je pense
c'est le cadet de leurs soucis je fais
dans le sens d'alexandre effectivement
même les agglos chez si on prends grand
paris seine et oise régulièrement fait
les micro trottoirs pour voir si c'est
un petit peu entre et s'ils sont
appropriés puis cision de meilleure
visibilité des compétences de l'agglo
c'est déjà pas le cas donc pour la
fusion qui est quand même un espèce de
serpent de mer qui date depuis 2016
je pense que c'est encore un petit peu
tôt on ne sait plus qui s'occupe de quoi
ça c'est vrai que ça ressort assez
souvent lorsqu'on faux mails et micro
trottoir sur les compétences des uns et
des autres mais oui c'est difficile
aussi
après c'est légitime et compréhensible
que deux citoyens ne se désintéresse un
peu sur ces questions qui intéressent
réellement que les dirigeants et les
pouvoirs publics quand les dirigeants
politiques et des pouvoirs lui même si
ça se traduit sur des impôts derrière
aussi les citoyens aiment bien savoir ce
qu'ils mettent dans leurs impôts aussi
ce qui se passe derrière british ou pas
d'ailleurs puisque si d'après ce que
j'ai compris en tout cas de la fusion
n'y a pas de d'augmentation d'impôts en
conséquence et puis ensuite sur le six
fusions rien y'a pas redécoupage
électoral puisque on validera sur les
mêmes cantons avec le même nombre d'élus
dans un premier temps tu alors si la
fusion ce que je me demande c'est qui
qui dirige qui s'entendent bien jusqu'à
présent
certainement oui aussi et apparemment il
ya un nom plus ou moins qui a été acquis
a été défini
je crois que pour et par ses 98 lors de
cette non lors de cette fameuse
rebondissement l'audition il n'y en a
plus papa remettre deux présidents
d'ailleurs mes parent ddd membres de
cette commission qui a annoncé de 98
pour être le 98 nouveau départ qu'il
faut savoir qu'une fusion entre le
bas-rhin et le haut-rhin va voir le jour
en 2021 donc c'est peut-être de bonne
augure bonne augure pour le 110 80 et 90
c'est pas les mêmes enjeux communs en
attendant faudra voter pour les
municipales là on s'en approche beaucoup
plus c'est le dernier sujet d'actualité
pour ce club de la presse en mars nous
irons aux urnes pour désigner nos élus
locaux maires conseillers communautaires
aussi dans les agglomérations communauté
de communes dans le département des
yvelines plus de 260 communes et
certaines vont forcément être suivie
avec beaucoup plus d'attention par les
différentes rédactions représenté ici
hakima et apport elles fm quelles sont
les communes qui vont un peu vous
intéressez j'aimerais qu'on s'intéresse
peut-être un peu à mantes la ville parce
que le maire lui a annoncé c'est le
sommaire du rassemblement national sur
la région ile de france même il a
annoncé qu'il se représentait
effectivement mantes-la-ville chez nous
c'est le top 5 et peuvent le la position
numéro 1 puisqu'il ya effectivement un
gros gros enjeu premier première ville
et rennes va rester sur rn puisqu'à
l'époque c'était pas l'appellation en
cours prise en 2014 est-ce que ça
restera alors chez nous on appelle ça un
petit peu une prise de guerre puisqu'il
est symbolique évidemment derrière cyril
d'une autre a déjà annoncé qu'il se
représentait et puis alors là on assiste
déjà à une multiplication des candidats
donc c'est effectivement une une
campagne qu'on va suivre avec la plus
grande attention et je pense qu'on sera
pas les seuls les serveurs qui aura pas
d'alliance entre les différentes
différentes tendances de gauche comme de
droite applique un tracé hockey un
moment
restons-en là vraiment la campagne
démarre ça a été évoqué je pense que moi
je laisserai la bible peut être
complétée je pense que netflix de peut
faire une ou plusieurs des saisons même
si c'est assez extraordinaire déjà il
faut rappeler qu'en 2014
ce monsieur était lui-même d'extrême
droite et angulaires sur un coin de rue
angulaire par des petits calculs de
notamment de monique brochot l'ancien
maire qui rend politique dispute 10 ne
font pas vain
sauf que que madame rochois fait ce
calcul là on a vu le résultat accès et
d'ailleurs elle est encore dans les
coulisses de la prochaine élection 2020
elle ne rêve que d'un compte d'un poste
de conseiller communautaire conseiller à
la gp c'est au mas de là où je suis je
suis extrêmement
inquiet pour cette ville qui aujourd'hui
dirigée par l arn comme vous le dites
mais par l'extrême droite parce qu'il
faut appeler un chat un chat et si
renault tda membres de l'extrême droite
vous avez vous prenez cette ville vous
avez autour d'elle magnanville qui en
l'espace de six ans a énormément évolué
vous avez à côté buchelay qui en
vous avez mantes la jolie qui est à côté
de la même manière qui a énormément
évolué voilà une vie où s'est rien passé
pendant six ans et quand je lis les
commentaires du maire qui dit oui mais
la dette et maîtriser oui mais quand on
maîtrise le net je me fais on ne fait
rien et aujourd'hui un mental on ne fait
rien et ensuite après avoir dit cela
moi je trouve que l'extrême droite a un
fonctionnement qui est bien particulier
serre que la tendance que il travaille
en famille le maire actuel vit avec la
direccte général des services ont la vie
on a vu les le pen on a vu les menaces
arrive dans sa rivale partis politiques
maintenant on voit les notamment que la
vie c'est quand même ubuesque d'avoir et
le maire qui vit avec la directrice
générale des services pourrait s'arrêter
balkany aussi qu'il cédera à l'extrême
droite qui met ses sidiki fonctionner
sur le même si ce cadeau était vu les
pertes qu'elle soit et ce n'est pas le
cas de la directrice générale des
services donc je trouve que 20 à un
moment pour une vie qui ne se passera
rien pour une ville de 20 + 20 militants
il ne se passe rien depuis six ans c'est
extrêmement inquiétant alors pour
revenir au contexte politique et
notamment à la à la multiplication des
listes c'est tout le mot pense
contrairement à ce qu'on croit qui peut
l'emporter là les verts parce que aux
dernières élections
européenne une poussée des gens qui ne
se concrétisent pas forcément d'un
scrutin à l'autre rénale par le passé
européenne n'ont pas forcément beaucoup
de séquences sont les on a des listes
citoyenne qui sortent on a on a on a
la france a soumise avec carbone est ce
qui fait qu on est en train d'avoir
quasiment le même scénario 2014 et je
vous le dis d'avancé que vous allez
avoir une citoyenne vous allez voir deux
ou trois qui sont qui seront capables de
se maintenir
il va avoir des calculs parce que le
niveau très bas a inventé la vie le
niveau politique est très bas il va
avoir des calculs mathématiques qui qui
vont être faussé parce qu'on est on
n'est pas en maths quand on pas on fait
une élection municipale et on risque
d'avoir encore l'extrême droite à mantes
la ville après les municipales de 2020
par la faute par la faute et la bêtise
de quelques-uns qui n'ont pas compris
que l'intérêt général est plus important
que leur propre terre généralement une
prime au maire sortant lors des
municipales il ya toujours une prime au
maire sortant et puis aussi la question
de la participation après je n'ai pas
les chiffres en tête sur la sueur sur
mantes la ville mais les participations
ne sont pas toujours très élevé oui
effectivement j'ai pas les chiffres
encore un peu plus mais allait
revérifier ont parlé de biens de
mantes-la-ville par dont l'une des
communes qui sera suivie à suivre
pendant ces élections municipales il y
en a d'autres dans le département
alexandre remarquer qu'elles sont
accolés les communes que vous allez
suivre à la principale sur sa route vers
new line ça va être trappe
c'était la surprise ouais qui mémorise
des suivis au niveau national je pense
en k2 en cas de basculement
le maire sortant guy malandain maire
depuis 2001 92 ans qui se représente
pour un quatrième mandat
ce qui est loin de faire l'unanimité au
sein de sa majorité son adjoint aux
sports à lire à b qui se présente face à
lui des membres de massage à sa majorité
qu'on rejoint othman dassault est élu
d'opposition de droite donc du coup une
situation compliquée pour le maire guy
malandain vous coupe mais qui a reçu le
soutien des l'air on aime aussi alors
que alors que l'animateur du on peut
surtout se poser la question est-ce que
ça soutient parce que dans le contexte
de trappes
je suis très très loin de penser que
c'est une bonne chose que le même quel
que soit d'ailleurs que le maire sortant
notamment et le soutien de la république
en marche ceci dit othmana se trouve
face à lui et républicains a le soutien
du modèle sauf erreur de ma part ayant
même d un élu de la majorité de guy
malandain actuelle si vous arrivez
ailleurs suivre swire m qui ont ce
qu'ils soutiennent maintenant aussi
autres managers du comité local dans
marche qui avec magna donc il faut s'y
retrouver aussi des calculs politiciens
ont mis aussi sur trappe en mai de
l'autre côté du département mais c'est
la même chose si j'étais malade je
refuserais le soutien de la république
hommage fin juin sauf que sa première
adjointe jeanine marre et dans sa folie
il ya un électorat qui est qui est
profondément pas en marche du tout et
que et que le fait d'avoir le soutien en
marche pour malandain va lui faire
perdre énormément de voix sur sa partie
gauche et est en marche pas demain parce
que ça peut profiter peut-être à rabais
parce qu'il a le soutien de benoît hamon
lui je pose la question parce qu'en
général benoît hamon quel ancien député
de cette 11e circonscription est bien
implantée et même aux différentes
élections au scrutin même présidentielle
il a fait des bons scores aux élections
européennes il a encore arrivés en tête
et là il a clairement appuyé ali rebeihi
est venue lors de son lancement de
campagne
après est-ce qu'il sera sur sa liste
pour le soutenir vraiment jusqu'au bout
c'est une autre question
alors pour vous à répondre à votre
question est oui la réponse est
évidemment oui ça va énormément profité
à ligue arabe est tous ceux qui sont
profondément de gauche parce que tu
rappes a toujours été une ville de
gauche où vont se poser la question est
ce que parce que derrière en marche est
ce qu'on va voter
macron je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit toutefois que si on regarde
au niveau départemental pour changer un
peu de communes et et a terminé sur
cette page municipal y avait d'autres
communes mais on aura le temps d'en
reparler au soir les autres des autres
clubs de la presse
j'aimerais quand même qu'on porte de
versailles c'est tout de même le chef
lieu du département et alors là sur
versailles même situation
didier baichère quel député de la
circonscription lui souhaite une liste
face au maire sortant françois de
mazières
alors que le sénateur martin lévriers et
qui est république en marche aussi lui
soutient françois de mazières et qui
fait partie de la majorité voilà il
souhaiterait aussi lui que qui se
représente avec le soutien et la bohème
c'est très divisé le silencieux
versailles a visé mais le maire est bien
en place françoise de françois de
mazières
je pense qu'il va pas trop de soucis à
ce faire je pense en vue des élections
municipales
en tout cas les cartes sont rebattues
vous qui avez suivi les élections
municipales par le passé est ce qu'il ya
un vrai changement avec depuis cette
élection présidentielle et l arrivée des
mano mâcon de witch est juste pour
revenir à votre question précédente
tous ces soutiens c'est aussi du
copinage
quand il vous parle on parlait de
trappes le modem soutien othman trou lr
soutiennent guy malandain et l'om le
patron du modem et élu à la région dans
la majorité le président othman nasro
à versailles le sénateur en place
extrêmement pote avec le le le maire
donc en réalité tous ses soutiens c'est
en fonction des copinages quand on parle
du nouveau monde non enfin on est
toujours dans un fonctionnement de
l'ancien monde
il faudra voir je reviens sur la
participation mais ça ça peut jouer
aussi et le fait que les électeurs
soient blasé quelquefois réussir et
justement n'ai plus envie de ce jeu là
ce qu'on remarque aussi énormément dans
cette campagne c'est que il ya six ans
tout le monde se battait pour avoir des
investitures oui alors que la personne
alors que plus personne n'en veut toutes
les listes par sans étiquette que des
lices participative ces dispositifs dans
un club de la presse et vouloir sauver
les uns et les autres mais quand on les
reçoit donc il passe sur le plateau il
nous précise bien on met sans étiquette
je suis apolitique savoir et à chaque
fois c'est la même chose oui sauf ceux
que personne ne connaît et là c'est ce
que voulait dire de leur jeu le soutien
de la république en marche
le club de la presse se poursuit sur
téléfilm sur tv 78 tsahia je les fais
j'ai dit et des petits ça m'a échappé
non tv 78,2 vous le savez et vie elles
fm aussi avec la participation de toutes
les nouvelles cette suite actus.fr on
passe aux personnalités du mois la
personnalité et du mois pour vous lahbib
eddaouidi directeurs des différentes
gazette
on en a parlé tout à l'heure de
champclause c'est catherine arnaud oui
c'est catherine r nous parce que ce
qu'elle a vécu ces dernières semaines
est extrêmement difficile des cantons
quand on est maire d'une petite commune
comme c'est le cas
on passe son temps à prendre que des
coûts et quand en plus on a des faits
divers d'une ampleur nationale
ça devient infernal puis ensuite vous
avez vous avez tous les jours des sujets
des articles qui de vernet tu crois que
la semaine enfin dimanche prochain il ya
un complément d enquête dessus vous avez
l'échelle internationale qui viennent
oui pour moi c'est vraiment une dame qui
a beaucoup souffert du fait d'être
d'être maire de chanteloup est il pour
moi c'est la personnalité du mois parce
qu'en plus elle a été courageuse
combative et debout mais c'est important
face à face à cette minorité dont on
parlait tout à l'heure que des gens
comme elle se dresse pour dire on et
l'ail puis on va reconstruire et puis on
va avancer puis vous vous n'aurez pas
gain de cause nous oui pour moi c'est la
personnalité du monde je continue son
tour de table pour vous hakima et hapoel
fm la personnalité du mois est une
féministe s'allume croisienne l'aurait
famille fabienne dorey une féministe
ils voient que ça veut sourire la vie du
féminisme et dean cette fuite
elle est auteure du livre l'envers de
flins une féministe révolutionnaire à
l'atelier pourquoi c'est notre
personnalité du mois sur l fm
bon je le disais tout à l'heure on est
la plus féminine des radios d'une part
mais on a été réceptif à son appel dans
le cas dans le sillon de la mobilisation
organisée sur le 24 novembre
initiée par le collectif nous tout
forcément
on souhaitait donner donner la parole à
des féministes du territoire qui avait
une liberté de ton
c'est son cas allait absolument livre et
puis surtout il y avait une situation un
petit peu cocasse c'est quel point tu
n'entres me sauver je lui misé votre vie
avant avant l'émission
on l'a reçu aux côtés de deux autres
militantes féministes du mantois marie
guidicelli et béatrice le mot haine et
puis effectivement je vois sur l'écran
la fameuse entreprise donc les sus de
l'ouest entreprises connu nationalement
et puis il ya aussi un phénomène aurait
brassé et non justement voilà et en fait
elle dénonce le sexisme ordinaire d'une
part la stratégie marketing bien entendu
et puis aussi la presse alors ça c'était
intéressant qui s'est fait selon d'après
elle le relais d'une success stories
locale avec une communication alors moi
aussi j'ai placé un jeu de mot une
communication infâme
on peut l'écouter peut-être se renvoie à
l'égalité vraie écoute
c'est dire que l'entreprise et ses
doutes et d'un non absolument ce qu'on a
deux et des prénoms et chaque camion un
prénom de femmes en accolade qui sont
très significatifs d'accord là une
monica en référence par hasard
l'entrepreneur à monica levinsky prêts
dont a absolument aucun nature et donc
nous on a on a on a réagi on pense
réellement que ce type de procédé
contribue à la violence faite aux femmes
c'est à dire que c'est le fait le lit de
la banalisation qui banalise des propos
qui font que ensuite on arrive au
féminicide fabien blu ray c'est votre
personnalité du mois
absolument féministe engagée et puis je
les rejoins sur l'idée que ça pose quand
même question
on s'en amuse mais je peux comprendre
que certains sourient ne s'impliquent
pas davantage mais les féministes sont
régulièrement attaqués campagne de
publicité sexiste
je sais pas si ça vous parle mais au
début des années 2000 il y avait la
campagne babette je la lis je l'avais
joué sur l'album fraîche et c'était
aussi pas de très bon ton dans le
contexte des violences conjugales et
puis des féminicides avec une imagerie
de la femme qui est enfin c'est le même
mot valise
voilà voilà ça ça banalise la bible oui
enfin moi j'ai toujours un peu de mal
avec tous ces gens
sur tel ou tel sujet qui vont à
l'extrême fin cette société existe
depuis 15 ans et on peut reprocher
beaucoup de choses à la presse je pense
que demain elle n'aurait comme tous ceux
qui se sont soudain opposés ont aussi
cherché le buzz médiatique et ils sont
en plein dedans donc je crois que vous
leur avez donné une visite à thé sur ce
sujet plus consensuel en kit ce kit ce
sujet là on va parler avec vous
alexandre marqué pour toutes les
nouvelles d'un danseur christophe ouest
oui j'ai fait plus léger pour faire le
christ et christophe ouest ouest il a 25
ans c'est un danseur professionnel il
est originaire de voisins-le-bretonneux
et il sera devant de la scène dans les
jours qui viennent qui sera l'opéra
bastille du 25 novembre au 26 décembre
est en fait je me disais que c'était
l'occasion de mettre en avant cette
cette compagnie de danse et dissidence
avant à bretonneux et à à maurepas qui a
été créée par olaf sidi bel-abbes sidiki
et qu'ils étaient donc les anciens de
l'acbb amber beurre et du cougaing fort
mais je n'ai vraiment dès le début oui
et qui a formé beaucoup de danseurs qui
sont devenus qu'on fait des carrières
mamady novart crois qu'elle chorégraphe
est cadencé avec maître gims et
christophe reste lui-même c'est à
thouars avec la semaine dernière avec
ntm aussi froid j'ai fait beaucoup
christophe wells où il a notamment dansé
avec shy'm soprano kamel ouali est donc
là pendant un mois il va être à
l'affiché de l'opéra bastille avec un
opéra ballet le prince igor y avait
consacré un portrait alors cet article
et puis cet article et puis à bientôt
vous le retrouverez aussi sur sur notre
antenne nous allons aller le rencontrer
de mon côté pour les personnalités elles
sont deux j'aimerais vous parler de deux
chefs de cuisine jeunes ils partagent un
autre point commun un autre point commun
dans le gault et millau 2020 il figure
au palmarès
ils font partie justement de ces jeunes
en devenir jean baptiste lavergne mozart
animaux à zahrani et xavier pincemin se
sont ils font partie des six grands de
demain de ce guide gastronomique
nous avions déjà reçu à l'antenne de tv
soixante dix huit morceaux choisis de
ces entretiens
moi j'ai grandi dans un restaurant mais
grand-mère remontée devant la maison des
bois ou la sainte apolline entre plaisir
et pontchartrain est une vieille auberge
avec des jolis produits donc j'ai
toujours vu ça pour mon gaz et les sols
venir tout ça donc j'ai des souvenirs
quand même j'ai un rapport à la mickey
j'ai jamais voulu ouvrir mon restaurant
parce que j'ai toujours voulu être chef
dans un palace c'était mon rêve d'enfant
alain ducasse tout ça c'était incroyable
finalement il y a il ya quoi ya deux ans
je me suis dit mais en fait si j'ai un
patron toujours je crois jamais faire ce
que je veux dans ma cuisine
ce qu'il faut savoir que les directeurs
ils ont leur mot à dire sur le plat
alors j'ai voulu faire ma cuisine où je
vais aussi d'ouvrir mon restaurant et au
final bas et cherche
j'ai voulu la liberté de la créativité
jean baptiste la vergne mozart à nice et
j'ai corps je passe mon nom cette fois
ci et xavier pincemin que l'on vient
d'entendre parmi les six grands de
demain pour le gault et millau 2020 un
mot peut-être sur xavier pincemin vous
avez peut-être déjà entendu en tout cas
vu sa tête c'est le vainqueur de top
chef de l'édition 2016 elle son
restaurant lui et au 10 boulevard du roi
et il a ouvert son établissement dans la
cité royale en juillet dernier seulement
avant que ce 9 ans est un pur produit
versaillais il a grandi là bas il a été
formé aussi au trianon palace alors son
plat signature peut-être tartare de
boeuf huîtres salicorne et concombres
confie servier dans une coquille
d'huître géante en porcelaine de limoges
est-ce que ça ça fait l'unanimité ou
est-ce qu'il ya débat là on va
s'entendre lundi c'est extraordinaire de
voir des gens
qui ont une telle passion pour leur
métier qui fascine on est aussi jeanne
aussi jeune c'est lui comme jean
baptiste ont tous les deux moins de 30
ans et l'un des entrepreneurs et
entrepreneurs ils ont tous fondé par le
même ils se sont forgés eux mêmes et on
va entendre parler d'eux dans les
prochaines années et chance pour nous
ils sont tous les deux à versailles le
club de la presse se poursuit avec une
dernière rubrique qui prochainement la
une
[Musique]
le club de la presse avec cette rubrique
bientôt à la une pour vous acquis maria
rédactrice en chef lfm ce sera la venue
du préfet des yvelines dans vos locaux
absolument prochainement et le préfet
des yvelines face au jeune une semaine
ça se passe mercredi 4 décembre prochain
prochain ça se passera en direct avec un
débat sur les relations entre
représentants de l'état et population et
puis un focus sur les jeunes cette fois
ci donc les jeunes pourront poser
directement leurs questions aux préfets
précarité étudiante relations entre
police et jeunesse des quartiers on en
parlé un petit peu tout à l'heure ou
encore laïcité on leur a laissé carte
blanche
un an après l'incident du lycée de
syntaxe très médiatisée elles sont des
lycéens de mantes la jolie
c'est bien que le préfet se prêtent au
jeu il a des questions paravent comment
ça se passe ça a été compliqué à monter
cet entretien il ne devra pas les
questions en amont non enfin c'est pas
prévu je ne suis pas non mais comment ça
y est c'est difficile à monter ce genre
de rencontre où est ce qu'ils se prêtent
au jeu le préfet c'est bien aussi
d'expliquer aux téléspectateurs et aux
auditeurs l'envers du décor moi je
trouve qu'on a un préfet qui est
extrêmement disponibles jusque pour que
pour qu'ils viennent on va le fourrer
dans une petite radio pas dans une
grande radio une grande radio radio
associative qui émet sur plusieurs
départements je trouve ça ouais et puis
puisque oui je pense que
les habitants mais pas seulement des
sites et d'ailleurs mais envie
d'entendre le premier représentant de
l'état sur des sujets comme comme ceux
évoqués par paref ma question si je peux
me permettre de poser une question à qui
masse et qui prépare les questions est
ce que c'est vraiment open barque pour
les jeunes c'est elles qui choisissent
les ans en contre c'est danser dans le
canon mène des ateliers radio am fm
radio tout au long de l'année notamment
les mercredis et pendant les vacances
scolaires donc l'émission et préparer
l'ordre les mercredis mercredi sur les
ateliers il y quand je dis qu'ils ont
carte blanche c'est qu'ils posent leurs
questions
la seule chose sur laquelle on va
intervenir c'est la forme parfaite
puisque des lycéens sont parfois assez
direct à ces caches et bon voilà on peut
arrondir un petit peu mais on modifie
pas il n'ya pas de sélection de il n'y a
pas de censure voilà si c'est la
question n'y a pas de n'y a pas de
censure elles fm radio bientôt à la une
pour l fm bientôt à la une sur toutes
les nouvelles et 7,8 actus.fr alexandre
marqué le carrefour de la manne me donne
plus gros dossier pour soumettre un
dossier ouais c'est un projet très
attendu depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années il se trouve à l'intersection
de trois communes donc maurepas à
coignières et la verrière donc le projet
c'est de d'abaisser la n10 faire passer
un pont particules n 10 pour la manne de
relier la verrière d'un côté à maurepas
et coignières de l'autre donc la
concertation bien débuté pendant un mois
il y aura 10 seulement des études dans
l'année à venir
et si tout va bien si tout va bien les
travaux devraient démarrer en 2024 pour
une mise en service en 2000 26 les frais
de l'opération c'est 20 millions d'euros
à peu près beaucoup de travaux entre la
malle me donne la nationale 10 qui
attend toujours l'enfouissement aussi
débutée l'an prochain alors à la dirif
qui s'explique maîtres d'ouvragé du
projet ont dit que les deux projets sont
bien distincts n'ont rien à voir mais il
y aura forcément une période je pense ça
sera un peu compliqué pour les
automobilistes ou les deux projets vont
se pourrait que l'un sur l'autre
pour ce elle l'est déjà au quotidien oui
là c'est la gestion encore plus fort en
seconde période les côtés des gazettes
alors sur rien les rites de 50 en une
ligne on a la même une queue que nos
confrères puisque ce sera également le
carrefour de la maldonne / / la gazette
en yvelines qui est distribué sur tout
pays ou d'année et gps et haut
c'est-à-dire de poissy qu'on flora cher
jusqu'à revenir old boys
on va parler des associations d'usagers
en faire les associer dans les
transports sochaux qui font enfin on
trouve qu'ils font tous font beaucoup de
bruit et est donc on enquête sur eux et
comment il fonctionne et c'est donc on
fait un beau sujet a priori beau dossier
sur sur les associations transports
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce club de la presse avant de le
refermer ce premier numéro coup d'oeil
sur la lune de la gazette
à 50 ans du 19 novembre dernier numéro
sorti consacré aux violences conjugales
dont nous avons parlé d'ailleurs depuis
le grenelle les associations de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise note
une hausse des signalements et puis elle
a une de toutes les nouvelles de ce 20
novembre
vous voyez les caméras piétons qui ont
été installés sur les policiers
versaillais merci à kimaya rédactrice en
chef de l fm
lahbib eddaouidi là directeur des
gazettes gazette saint-quentin gazette
en yvelines et puis alexandre marquet
responsable du secteur de saint-quentin
pour toutes les nouvelles aussi présent
sur 7 8 actus.fr on se retrouve très
bientôt pour un prochain club de la
presse
[Musique]